Welcome to the lesson on evaluation metrics.
Evaluation metrics are how you can tell if your machine learning algorithm is
getting better and how well you're doing overall.
>> And we are at my favorite place in the entire company,
which is the foosball table where I get to evaluate it myself,
pretty much every day by applying or playing my colleagues and see how I score.
>> And people like me who aren't quite as good at foosball might not
use wins and losses as our evaluation metrics, but maybe, I would say
something like how many goals do I score overall or how long does the game last?
>> In machine learning, it's really important that you know your evaluation and
understand how to apply your evaluation to measure the right result.
>> And that's what we'll be talking about in this class, so shall we?
>> Let's play a game.
>> All right.